bonjour
aujourd'hui on va parler de la mort et
on va en parler dans la joie et la bonne
humeur parce qu'il en a marre qu en
occident à chaque fois qu'on parle de la
mort on sent obligé de faire une tête
d'enterrement
quand on parle de la mort il est convenu
d'adopter un air grave un air sérieux et
la mort est un événement qu'on associe
immédiatement à la tristesse mais on va
arrêter l'hypocrisie cinq minutes et
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont la
mort c'est comme les sdf séquence est
sous nos yeux qu'on s'en soucie voilà
donc ça c'est fait et si vous êtes déjà
choqué je vous dit d'entrée de jeu vous
n'êtes pas prêt pour la suite mais
c'était nécessaire de briser un petit
peu la glace pour détendre l'atmosphère
sur ce sujet et aujourd'hui on va voir
avec epicure en quoi la mort ne doit pas
nous effrayer
pourquoi la mort ne doit pas être
crainte et pour ça on va commencer par
partir d'un constat qui est que dans
l'histoire de la philosophie la mort a
très souvent été associée à la
souffrance et à l' angoisse l'angoissé
métaphysique de la mort c'est quelque
chose qu'on retrouve chez énormément
d'auteur et pour certains la mort et
même ce qui structure la condition
humaine l'humaine condition se
définirait par notre caractère mortel
par notre finitude temporel est plus que
la mort la conscience de la mort serait
la marque de notre condition
parce qu'après tout si on n'a pas
conscience de la mort de la mort qui
vient gagne a aucune raison que la mort
soit source d'angoissé
il n'y a aucune raison qu'elle soit pour
nous une préoccupation métaphysique
donc on va rappeler très brièvement le
nom de quelques auteurs pour qui notre
condition mortelle fait partie
intégrante de la définition de la nature
humaine
pour freud on l'a vu dans la dernière
vidéo
l'angoissé de la mort constitue l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles l'homme a
inventé dieu pour lesquelles l'homme a
inventé la religion car la religion nous
promet une vie après la mort la religion
nous promets qu'après notre vie
terrestre
nous connaîtrons une vie éternelle une
vie éternelle auprès de dieu si nous
avons fait le bien ou dans les flammes
de l'enfer
si notre vie a été marquée par le péché
mais dans tous les cas il ya l'idée que
après la mort la vie continue s
parce que l'idée d'une vie qui
s'arrêterait définitivement nous paraît
totalement absurde nous dit freud eux
que nous avons inventé dieu pour
conjurer cette absurdité un autre
philosophe qui considère que la
conscience de la mort fait partie
intégrante de notre nature c'est
heidegger à deux guerres qui définissent
l être humain comme un être vers la mort
on trouvera parfois un être pour la mort
selon les traductions zain dessous todd
et selon heidegger c'est ce souci de la
mort qui vient c'est préoccupations
métaphysiques qui ne quitte jamais notre
existence qui fait que l'homme est
constamment plongées dans l'inquiétude
au sens littéral la non qui étudie le
souci permanent et c'est seulement à la
condition que nous acceptions notre sort
d'être mortel que nous pouvons sortir du
souci sortir de l' inquiétude et accèder
à l'authenticité
pascal on l'a vu considère également que
notre condition de mortel était
absolument structurantes pour pascal
c'est parce que l'homme est incapable de
demeurer en repos dans une chambre c'est
parce que l'homme est incapable
d'oublier sa condition mortelle qu'il a
besoin de se divertir qu'il a besoin de
dévier son esprit le dévier ses pensées
de cette angoisse fondamentale de la
mort l'homme se divertit par le jeu par
le loisir par le travail pour détourner
son esprit de cette vérité à la fois
effroyable est inévitable
pour schopenhauer la mort et la marque
de l'absurdité de notre existence
on sait que pour schopenhauer les sens
intime du monde qu'il appelle la volonté
à laquelle nous essayons de donner du
sens à travers la représentation
cette volonté fondamentalement
incompréhensible inaccessible à
l'entendement humain c'est quelque chose
qui nous dépasse radicalement et toute
prétention à comprendre le sens de
l'existence d'autres prétentions à
comprendre ce qu'est la volonté lui
apparaît comme étant seulement la marque
de notre orgueil
la vie est incompréhensible parce que la
mort est incompréhensible
elles mêmes l'incompréhensible et
partant de là notre existence
even montaigne quant à lui disait que
philosopher c'était apprendre à mourir
apprendre à mourir c'est à dire
apprendre à accepter l'idée de la mort
parce que pris dans son sens littéral
apprendre à mourir
ça n'aurait pas beaucoup de sens nous
n'apprenons pas à mourir nous mourrons
et nous n'avons pas le choix et qu'on
les a pris ou pas le résultat sera le
même mais ce que voulait dire montaigne
c'est que si on peut pas
chez que la mort nous emporte si on ne
peut pas se soustraire à la mort à cet
inéluctable par excellence on peut en
revanche apprendre à accepter cette idée
est ainsi apaiser notre angoisse
notre angoisse de quitter ce monde qui
résume le tout de notre existence car
qui existe t-il à part notre existence
faut bien se rendre compte que l'
angoisse de la mort ce n'est pas juste
un concept et c'est une expérience
l'expérience intérieure une réalité
intérieure
une réalité qui nous prend aux tripes et
aux neurones il faut savoir que cette
vision pour le moins sombre de la nature
humaine
cette idée d'une humanité qui se
définirait par sa condition mortelle n'a
pas toujours été en vigueur chez les
philosophes et notamment chez les
anciens on trouve l'idée que la mort
n'avait pas ce caractère sinistre et
mélodramatique qu'on lui prête dans
l'occident moderne
par exemple chez platon la mort n'était
rien d'autre que la fin de notre
existence terrestre et le début de la
vie dans le monde intelligible
on sait que pour platon l'existence
terrestre n'est rien d'autre qu'une
projection en mouvement de la réalité
intelligible d'une réalité éternelle et
transcendante
or pour platon nous sommes connectés à
cette réalité
éternel par notre âme par la partie
rationnelle de notre âme que platon
appelé le nous et qui fait que lorsque
notre vie terrestre s'achève la vie de
notre âme continue elle continue sous
d'autres cieux
elle continue dans un monde auquel nous
n'avons pas accès en tant qu'être
physique mais selon platon cette réalité
à laquelle nous n'avons pas accès c'est
la vraie réalité il n'y a donc pas lieu
de s'en inquiéter
chez les
siens la mort ne devait pas être redouté
tout simplement parce qu'elle fait
partie des choses qui ne dépendent pas
de nous la mort c'est l'inévitable la
mort c'est l'inéluctable autrement dit
il ne dépend pas de nous de mourir ou de
ne pas mourir ce n'est pas quelque chose
sur quoi nous avons un droit de veto
c'est pas quelque chose sur quoi nous
avons notre mot à dire
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve chez
de nombreux philosophes cette idée que
la mort à ce caractère angoissant parce
qu'elle est ce sur quoi il n'y a rien à
dire
la main on n'est pas un objet de
discours la mort n'est même pas un objet
de pensée
tout simplement parce qu'on ne peut pas
penser quelque chose dont on ne peut pas
faire l'expérience
tout ce que l'on peut dire de la mort
c'est la manière dont elle nous affecte
la manière dont cela représente et ce
qu'elle constitue dans les faits c'est à
dire un retrait du monde et c'est cette
idée de retrait du monde
le fait de tirer sa révérence qui en
fait un objet philosophique à la fois
effrayant et fascinant et c'est là qu'on
arrive à la conception donné par epicure
de la mort qui se résume dans cette
citation célèbre la mort n'est rien plus
exactement la mort n'est rien pour nous
et aujourd'hui on va se pencher sur
cette idée
comment faut-il comprendre cette
citation la mort n'est rien parce que de
prime abord cette phrase paraît absurde
qu'est ce que ça signifie la mort n'est
rien bien sûr que si c'est quelque chose
la mort c'est la disparition c'est
l'anéantissement
c'est la fin de notre monde eh bien oui
mais justement nous dit epicure la mort
n'est rien parce que la mort c'est la
disparition alors pour comprendre cette
conception qui vous paraîtra pour
l'instant peut être un peu obscur on va
commencer par rappeler que epicure était
un philosophe matérialiste matérialiste
je le précise tout de suite ça ne veut
pas dire qu epicure était intéressé par
les biens matériels
le matérialisme en philosophie c'est la
vision selon laquelle tout est matière
tout ce qui existe est de nature
matérielle de nature matérielle ça
signifie tout simplement de nature
physique de nature corpusculaire ou
moléculaires et se trouve qu'ils piqûre
était un atomiste c'est à dire qu'ils
considéraient que tout ce qui existe
dans notre monde physique n'est rien
d'autre qu'un assemblage d'atomes
c'est à dire de briques élémentaires
insécables insécables signifiant qu' on
ne peut pas les diviser on ne peut pas
les fragmenter
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il existe une
réalité subatomiques autrement dit qu'il
existe un an de ça de l'atome mais dans
l'antiquité
c'était déjà pas mal d'envisager l'atome
d'envisager cette idée de corps
élémentaire invisibles à l'oeil nu qui
ne peut pas être divisé car alors
comment comprendre la solidité du monde
matériel
comment comprendre le fait que notre
main ne passe pas à travers les objets
si on n'envisage pas d'une manière ou
d'une autre
cette idée d'atomes cette idée de
briques élémentaires mais toujours est
il que pour epicure la nature même de
notre monde
c'est la matière la matière composée
d'atomes composé de corpuscules qui
existe de manière immuable qui existe de
manière éternelle
autrement dit pour epicure la matière a
toujours été là elle n'a ni début ni fin
et si on veut contredire epicure en lui
demandant pourquoi les corps
apparaissent et disparaissent
pourquoi les étrons une naissance et
mort bien et puis que répondra que ce
n'est pas la matière qui constituent ces
êtres qui apparaît ou qui disparaît
c'est simplement
l'assemblage de la matière si vous
préférez tout être est le produit d'une
combinaison de matières et lorsqu'un
corps meurt la matière qui le composent
ne disparaît pas elle se décompose et ne
manquera pas de se recomposer par la
suite
autrement dit chez epic urnes on trouve
l'idée que la matière se perpétue dans
le temps à travers la diversité de ces
assemblages et on retrouve ici la
célèbre devise de lavoisier qui a
justement emprunté à la pensée antique
rien ne se perd rien ne se crée tout se
transforme
tout se transforme parce que tout est
matière et si tout est matière ça
signifie que notre âme elle même et
matière alors entendons nous bien
dans l'antiquité l'existence de l'âme
était quelque chose d'admis par tous
mais simplement tout le monde n'avait
pas la même conception de la nature de
l'âme
l'âme étymologiquement annie mousse
c'est ce qui anime c'est le souffle de
vie pour platon l'âme se décomposait en
trois parties une partie matérielle une
partie sensible et une partie
rationnelle ou spirituelle pour platon
la partie spirituelle de notre âme ne
subsiste après notre mort physique alors
que pour epicure lorsque notre corps
moeurs notre âme meurent aussi
si vous préférez la mort de l'individu
est une mort totale à la fois physique
et spirituelle on ne retrouve pas chez
piqûre le dualisme de platon cette idée
que l'âme et le corps serait deux choses
indépendante de choses qui auraient leur
existence propre
pour epicure l'âme et le corps sont
intimement liés et ce qui advient au
moment de la mort c'est leur séparation
leur désagrégation
et c'est ce matérialisme des piqûres qui
permet de comprendre pourquoi selon lui
la mort n'est pas à craindre car que
nous dit epicure
il nous dit que l'existence peut se
résumer à la sensation en ce sens
epicure préfigurent ce qu'on appellera
plus tard l'empirisme c'est à dire le
courant qui considère que tout n'est
qu'expérience expérience au sens de ce
que l'on éprouve de ce que l'on vit sur
le plan sensorielle pour epicure tout
n'est que sensations et la séparation de
l'âme et du corps qui se produit au
moment de la mort
cette séparation signe la fin de toutes
sensations la fin de toute expérience
sensible de la réalité et donc si la
mort n'est rien d'autre que la fin de la
sensation que la cessation de toute
expérience sensorielle et bien ça
justifie l'idée que la mort n'est rien
car comment la cessation de toute
expérience pourrait-elle être quelque
chose comme en l'absence de toute chose
pourrait-elle être considéré comme
quelque chose pour epicure il n'y a pas
lieu de craindre la mort car la mort au
niveau de l'individu
ce n'est rien d'autre que l'absence ce
n'est rien d'autre que le néant
or dans le néant il se produit rien il
ne se passe rien tout ça
parce que faire l'expérience du néant
c'est une contradiction dans les termes
il ne peut pas y avoir d'expérience du
néant la mort n'est rien parce qu'en
l'absence de toute sensation
il est impossible d prouver quoi que ce
soit
l'idée des piqûres c'est qu'on ne
rencontre jamais la mort on la rencontre
jamais parce que tant qu'on est en vie
la mort n'est pas là et quand on meurt
on n'est plus là pour faire l'expérience
de la mort on ne rencontre jamais la
mort parce que pour rencontrer quelque
chose il faut en éprouver la sensation
or au moment notre mort nous n'avons
plus de sensations donc nous ne pouvons
pas faire l'expérience de la mort la
mort
c'est ce qui met fin à notre expérience
en résumé la mort ne nous concerne pas
la mort nous la rencontrons jamais et
parce que nous la rencontrons jamais
nous n'avons aucune raison d'en avoir
peur alors évidemment vous constatez
qu'il y a dans cette conception des
piqûres ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
approche logique de la mort n'approche
logique de la mort ça signifie qu'on se
pose la question de ce qu'est la mort
fondamentalement de sa définition
technique et c'est à partir de cette
définition technique qu on en conclut
qu'il n'ya pas en avoir peur si la mort
ne peut pas se définir comme une réalité
dont on fait l'expérience
mais justement comme l'absence de toute
expérience ça signifie que pour
l'individu la mort n'existe pas et pour
vous le faire comprendre
je vais vous poser une simple question
avez vous déjà eu peur de n'être avez
vous déjà eu peur de venir au monde et
là normalement en entendant cette
question vous avez un petit franchement
de sourcils
ans y at-il à demander si on a déjà eu
peur de n'être on n'a jamais eu peur de
n'être parce qu'avant de naître on ne
pouvait pas avoir peur pour avoir peur
il faut exister il faut déjà être né
vous n'avez jamais eu peur de n'être pas
ce que vous ne pouvez avoir peur qu'à
partir du moment où vous êtes déjà
et donc quand vous n'existiez pas vous
ne vous posiez aucune question
par définition
ce que nous dit epicure c'est que c'est
exactement la même chose avec la mort on
se pose la question de la mort
on s'inquiète de la mort parce qu'on est
vivant il faut être vivant pour être
inquiet mais ce faisant on est inquiet
de quelque chose qui n'existe pas et
s'inquiétait de quelque chose qui
n'existe pas s'inquiéter de quelque
chose dont nous ne ferons jamais
l'expérience ça n'a pas de sens la mort
n'est rien si ce n'est un problème de
vivant si ce n'est un problème
d'individus qui ne sont pas confrontés à
ce problème
tout simplement parce qu'on peut pas
être confronté à ce problème nous n'y
serons jamais confrontés nous ne vivront
jamais notre mort en réalité la mort que
nous vivons c'est la mort des autres
c'est la mort de nos proches et qui a
l'occasion nous rappelle qu'un jour ou
l'autre c'est nous qui allons mourir
mais notre confrontation à la mort
ce n'est pas et ce ne sera jamais la
confrontation à notre propre mort ce
sera toujours la confrontation à la mort
d'autrui
ce qui nous affecte dans la morne ce qui
nous attriste ce qui nous fait de la
peine c'est la perte d'un être cher ce
qui nous attriste dans la mort c'est de
ne plus pouvoir faire l'expérience de
ceux que nous aimons c'est de ne plus
pouvoir rire avec eux parler avec eux
vivre avec eux au fond ce qui nous
attriste dans la mort c'est le manque
que cette mort créés chez nous au fond
si la main
rend triste c'est par égoïsme les larmes
que vous versez à la mort d'un proche
ce sont les larmes du manque ce sont les
larmes de l'absence l'absence qui vous
fait du mal l'absence qui vous fait
souffrir mais la souffrance liée à la
mort c'est d'abord votre souffrance
c'est pas la souffrance du défunt c'est
pas la souffrance de celui qui est mort
parce que celui qui est mort ne
souffrent plus et ce n'est pas sa mort
qui l'a fait souffrir
c'est ce qui a précédé sa mort pour le
mourant le plus difficile n'est pas la
mort le plus difficile c'est tout ce qui
précède la mort et si le mourant souffre
avant de partir il faut bien le dire
sa mort est pour lui une libération
la mort nous attriste pour des raisons
égoïstes pour des raisons égocentrique
l'égocentrisme peut parfois porter le
vêtement la sensibilité ce qui nous
attriste dans la mort d'un proche
ce n'est pas la mort de ce proche
c'est le fait qu'il va nous manquer
c'est le fait que nous soyons privé de
sa présence privé des rires qui nous
procurer ou de la tendresse qu'il nous
offrait et c'est bien normal
il ne s'agit pas de changer sans qu'il
s'agisse
en avoir conscience et de l'assumer il
s'agit
entendre et d'accepter que la mort des
autres nous fait du mal à nous c'est à
nous qu'elle fait du mal la mort des
autres ce n'est pas à ceux qui partent
c'est à ceux qui restent car pour
souffrir
il faut être là et la mort des autres
est un rappel de notre propre mort à
venir une mort que nous associons
forcément à la tristesse que la mort des
autres engendre ce n'est pas la douleur
liée à la mort qui nous fait peur c'est
la tristesse que notre mort va laisser
derrière elle mais l'angoissé de la mort
ce n'est pas seulement ça c'est aussi
l'angoissent de ne plus être celle
angoisses liées à la conscience que nous
ne sommes pas immortels
or nous avons un désir d'immortalité
nous avons un désir d'exister au-delà
des limites naturelles
au delà des limites imposées par
l'univers les anciens auraient qualifié
sa du bri la démesure la déraison le
fait de désirer
au delà de ce qui est prévu par la
nature on se
que pour les stoïciens désirer quelque
chose qui ne dépend pas de nous
c'est pure folie
le désir d'être immortel est indésirable
sur deux car c'est le désir de
l'impossible n'ont pas de l'impossible à
nos yeux non pas d'un impossible qui
pourrait devenir possible par l'audace
l'espoir et la persévérance d'un
impossible non négociables d'un
impossible qui ne demande pas notre avis
nous avons le désir d'immortalité
car dans la mort nous perdons tous nous
perdons absolument tout c'est pour ça
que
trouvons refuge dans le divertissement
parce que le divertissement nous
dispense de trouver l'acceptation or
l'acceptation et le seul chemin possible
si l'on peut dire
nous accepterons notre mort de gré ou de
force
mais si pour epicure nous devons
accepter la mort c'est parce que dans la
mort l'angoissent disparaît la
souffrance disparaît le regret disparaît
dans la mort tout disparaît y compris
toutes les raisons pour lesquelles nous
craignons la mort
nous craignons la mort parce que nous
sommes vivants mais c'est parce que nous
sommes vivants que craindre la mort est
absurde
au fond la peur de la mort et bien une
peur humaine c'est à dire la peur d'une
projection la peur d'une représentation
d'une non réalité
la peur est liée à notre capacité à
envisager envisager des scénarios
envisagés des situations des situations
qui n'existent pas au moment où nous les
envisageons mais qui se retrouvent à
exister virtuellement sous la forme de
représentation
nous sommes très forts pour nous créer
une réalité secondaire une réalité
mentale qui nous rend volontiers
masochistes nous aimons imaginer le pire
nous aimons imaginer ce qu'il n'irait
pas ce qui pourrait venir troubler le
moment présent car pour peu que vous ne
soyez pas dans un état de souffrance
physique permanente bien vous verrez que
votre souffrance mentale
c'est une souffrance liée à la
projection
c'est une souffrance liée non pas à une
réalité dont vous faites actuellement
l'expérience mais une réalité dont vous
pensez que vous pourriez faire
l'expérience
notre angoisse de la mort est
fondamentalement lié à notre inaptitude
à nous ancrer dans l'état présent c'est
parce que nous sommes incapables de
vivre l'instant présent autrement qu en
y injectant des pensées étrangères des
pensées qui n'ont rien à y faire que
nous sommes malheureux au fond se rendre
malheureux au présent du futur c'est
quelque chose dont nous sommes nous
mêmes responsables et ne pas être
présent au monde ne pas être présent à
cette seconde infinie qu'est notre vie
c'est quelque chose dont nous sommes
seuls coupables
je vais maintenant vous lire le texte
des piqûres dans lequel il expose cette
conception de la mort ce texte est
extrait de la lettre à ménécée je cite
prend l'habitude de penser que la mort
n'est rien pour nous car tout bien et
tout mal réside dans la sensation
or la mort et privations de toutes
sensations
par conséquent la connaissance de cette
vérité que la mort n'est rien pour nous
nous rend capables de jouir de cette vie
mortelle
non pas en y ajoutant la perspective
d'une durée infinie mais en nous
enlevant le désir de l'immortalité
car il ne reste plus rien à redouter
dans la vie pour qui a vraiment compris
que hors de la vie il n'y a rien de
redoutable on prononce donc de vaines
paroles quand on soutient que la mort
est à craindre
non pas parce qu elle sera douloureuse
et en réaliser mais parce qu'il est
douloureux de l'attendre
ce serait en effet une crainte veine est
sans objet que celle qui serait produite
par la tante d'une chose qui ne causent
aucun trouble par sa présence ainsi
celui de tous les maux qui nous donne le
plus d'horreur la mort n'est rien pour
nous puisque tant que nous existons la
mort n'est pas et que quand la mort
existe nous ne sommes plus donc la mort
n'existe ni pour les vivants ni pour les
morts puisqu'elle n'a rien à faire avec
les premiers et que les seconds ne sont
plus mais la multitude tantôt fui la
mort comme le pire des maux tantôt
l'appel comme le terme des maux de la
vie
lesage au contraire ne fait pas fi de la
vie et il n'a pas peur non plus de ne
plus vivre car la vie ne lui est pas à
charge et il n'estime pas non plus qu'il
y ait le moindre mal à ne plus vivre
il est fort possible que notre peur de
la mort ne soit rien d'autre que le
masque de notre peur de vivre car avoir
peur de la mort vivre dans cette
angoisse de la mort c'est se donner des
raisons de ne pas vivre de ne pas
affronter la vie de ne pas embrasser la
vie la mort et il
abl mais faut-il se répétait cette
vérité indéfiniment quelle est la
fonction de ce ressassement quelle est
la finalité de cette pensée s'ils
pensaient
amore le moyen de l'accepter si penser à
la mort et le moyen d'apprendre à mourir
alors cette pensée peut nous guider vers
la sagesse nous guider vers
l'acceptation et donc nous guider vers
la quiétude de la paix de l'âme mais si
le
et de s'empêcher de vivre si le but est
de se trouver des raisons de ne pas
vivre alors il est certain que penser à
la mort quand on est en vie c'est comme
penser au travail quand on est en
vacances
c'est comme penser à la maladie
quand on est en pleine santé c'est comme
penser au lendemain
quand on fait l'amour c'est dommage je
vous remercie
[Musique]